Conocido como Duterte el sucio, en
referencia al implacable carácter del
legendario personaje policíaco Harry el
sucio, o también conocido como el Donald
Trump filipino por las estridentes
declaraciones del candidato republicano
a la Casa Blanca, el nuevo presidente de
Filipinas es todo menos un político
convencional. Un personaje capaz de
reconocer públicamente su
responsabilidad por organizar y dirigir
escuadrones de la muerte;
capaz de insultar a Obama y al
mismísimo Papa; o de
frivolizar con la trágica violación de
una misionera australiana. En este video
te contamos porque es tan popular y qué
cambios depara su mandato para
Filipinas, e incluso para el mundo, porque
amigos de VisualPolitik esta
presidencia va a tener unas
implicaciones mucho más profundas de lo
que podríamos observar a simple vista.
Desde el año 2010, bajo el mandato del
anterior presidente,
Filipinas ha registrado un crecimiento
medio del pib del 6,2 por ciento, lo
que ha llevado a muchos expertos ha
considerar este país como un nuevo tigre
asiático.
De hecho, según datos del Banco Mundial,
en tan sólo una generación, este
país de más de 100 millones de
habitantes, podría dejar atrás
cualquier atisbo de pobreza.
Sin embargo, hoy por hoy las cosas son aún muy
distintas al escenario planteado por el
Banco Mundial:
Primero: el desempleo, la delincuencia y la
pobreza, son problemas generalizados
- "El Papá Francisco ha insistido en la
necesidad de luchar contra la
corrupción en un país en el que el 25
por ciento de la población vive bajo el
umbral de la pobreza".
Segundo: es uno de los cinco países más
corruptos del sudeste asiático; y
tercero: padece un interminable conflicto
armado en el sur del país con grupos
yihadistas, como Abu Sayyaf.
Por si no fuese suficiente, en Filipinas
prácticamente todo está bajo el
control de una poderosa oligarquía.
Diferentes estudios demuestran,
ojo, que tan sólo 40 familias controlan
más del 75 por ciento del pib
nacional, y que apenas que 178
familias, casi dinastías
político-económicas, se reparten
prácticamente todos los poderes del
Estado, incluyendo la jefatura de 73 de sus
80 provincias y el 80% de los escaños
del Parlamento.
- "Decenas de miles de manifestantes se
reunieron en la capital filipina.
La protesta fue contra toda la clase
política dominante del país".
En esta situación,
Duterte se presentó a las últimas
elecciones presidenciales como un
candidato ajeno a la élite, y que estaba
dispuesto a luchar contra los males que
azotan el país.
Ahora bien, ¿a qué se debe la gran
popularidad de éste personaje?
Rodrigo Duterte ha sido el alcalde de Davao,
la tercera ciudad más poblada de Filipinas,
durante los últimos 22 años, y desde
luego su gestión no ha pasado
desapercibida. Durante ese tiempo sus
excentricidades, continuas bravuconadas y
salidas de todo nos han dejado frases
tan sorprendentes y fuera de lugar como
estas:
Precisamente, esta
última afirmación hace referencia a
una de las claves de su enorme
popularidad en Davao.
Por cierto, este temazo que está sonando nos
lo ha mandado Sam, miembro de los Allrighters,
un grupo de León, suena bien
¿verdad? Echad un ojo a su canal,
os dejo el enlace en la descripción.
La que hasta su llegada al poder era una ciudad asediada por el
crimen,
hoy se ha transformado en una ciudad
bastante segura. Pero ¿cómo lo ha
conseguido?
Aquí está el problema, con mucha mano
dura y saltándose por completo el
estado de derecho. Aunque resulte
increíble, el propio Duterte reconoció
en televisión estar detrás los
escuadrones de la muerte que, según las
estimaciones disponibles, han sido
responsables, ojo, de la muerte de más de
mil personas.
- "El presidente filipino amenaza con salir
de la ONU, es la visceral respuesta de
Rodrigo Duterte te a la petición de la
Oficina de la ONU contra la droga y el
delito, de que abandone la política de
asesinatos a sospechosos de tráfico de
drogas."  Durante los 22 años al frente de
la alcaldía, las ejecuciones
extrajudiciales de traficantes de drogas,
violadores o incluso niños de la calle
se convirtieron en una imagen recurrente.
Además, prohibió que los menores
pudieran estar en la calle a partir de
las diez de la noche sin compañía de
un adulto o la venta y el consumo de
alcohol en establecimientos públicos a
partir de la una de la madrugada. Y más
allá de la lucha contra el crimen, el
empeño porque la ciudad estuviese
limpia y la total prohibición de
fumar en público, fueron otras de sus
obsesiones.
Pero ahora que es Presidente de la república
¿cuáles son sus intenciones?
pues básicamente
continuar con su sinestro plan de actuación
en Davao. De hecho, durante la campaña
electoral fue muy criticado por su
falta de propuestas o su absoluta apatía en
temas tan importantes como la política
económica, sobre la cual llegó a decir
que se limitaría a contratar a expertos
financieros para que se ocupasen de la
cuestión. Porque a él lo que realmente
le importa, su prioridad número uno es
reducir la criminalidad en Filipinas,
eso sí, con su estilo.
Durante la campaña electoral
llegó a decir que tras elegido daría
órdenes a la policía y al ejército de
perseguir a los criminales y matarlos a
todos,
en el marco de un plan de choque de seis
meses de duración que podría costar la
vida a 100.000 supuestos delincuentes.
Estamos, como veis, ante un personaje
terrorífico sin la más mínima
consideración por el estado de derecho.
¿Cuántas víctimas inocentes
habrá causado? Una sola es demasiado. ¿Acaso
la solución al crimen pasa por
convertir a la policía en una especie
de mafia busca recompensas? ¿Dónde está el límite?
No dudéis ni por un instante que no se
puede luchar contra la violencia
despreciando la justicia.
Este tipo de acciones al final siempre
se traducen en más violencia. Desde que
llegó al poder el 30 de junio de 2016,
se calcula que más de 3.000 personas
han perdido su vida con su plan contra
el crimen y para reforzar esta
estrategia acaba de anunciar la
implantación de la pena de muerte legal
en Filipinas  - " Lo que haré es instar al
Congreso para que la restaure, decía, y
será por ahorcamiento".
Otro de los puntos fuertes del programa
político de Duterte consiste en
transformar el sistema político y apostar
por una intensa descentralización:
el Gobierno de Manila se quedarán con
competencias como defensa, inmigración
o aduanas, mientras que las regiones asumirán
áreas como la educación o la salud.
Y cómo es una persona debe ideas firmes,
también va a extender la prohibición
de fumar en público
a todo el país. Hasta aquí la política
nacional, pero como dijimos al principio
del vídeo, su presidencia también
entraña importantes implicaciones
internacionales.
Duterte es el protagonistas de la que está siendo
una de las más grandes derrotas de la
Administración Obama en el Pacífico, y que
significa que Estados Unidos tendrá que
despedirse de quien hasta ahora ha sido
uno de sus más importantes aliados en
la región.
Y es que en opinión de Duterte la
cercanía a Washington le ha costado muy
caro a Filipinas, ya que ha limitado el
tráfico comercial y las inversiones en
el país de China.
- "El presidente de Filipinas, Rodrigo
Duterte ha reafirmado durante su visita
a Pekín, y tras su encuentro con su
homólogo chino Xi Jinping, su
intención de separarse de su aliado
Estados Unidos y acercarse a China".
Por ello, Duterte ha decidido apostar
fuerte: cambiar de bando e incluso
plantea exigir a Estados Unidos la
revisión de los acuerdos militares en
vigor y la salida de todas las tropas
estadounidenses apostadas en Filipinas.
Sólo el tiempo nos podrá decir que
hay de bravuconada o juego táctico en este
anuncio y cuánto de realidad, pero lo
que está claro es que hoy Manila mira
más a Pekín que a Washington.
En VisualPolitik seguiremos muy de cerca la
evolución de los acontecimientos.
Bueno, y tú ¿qué piensas de este
personaje? ¿Compartes nuestra apuesta
por respetar siempre el estado derecho?
Espero que te haya gustado este vídeo,
si ha sido así no dudes en darle a like.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.